the jurogan experience how's brooklyn
it's grim it's grim right now it's i've
lived in new york
for the majority of my life i love new
york city
and this is by far the grimmest i have
ever
seen it really i mean this winter
because it's everything that the
entire country is facing but it's the
worst
for covid it's also extremely cold
a lot of city services seem to have been
impaired in one way or another the
streets are covered in garbage and
ice and dog [ __ ] and
you can't pretty much the only thing
that i can do to maintain my sanity is
run but
everything including the outdoor running
track is covered in
ice and [ __ ] and so it's just this
dystopian
frozen pandemic landscape where every
um local business that i loved is
closing down
it's a dark time yeah um i
hear that about los angeles i saw a lot
of it but i got out early
i saw the writing on the wall and i was
looking to move in may
i just once once the lockdown got
extended
once they're like we're just gonna lock
down for two weeks to flatten the curve
i was like that makes sense and then
here we are in april
all the way through april here we are in
may and then i'm like oh they're never
gonna let us out of this
and then the crime started happening and
the you know it started it started
getting dark and i was like oh we gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here homeless
the homeless thing was like flowers
blooming out of rocks
like out of cracks in the concrete it's
like more tents
tenths tenths tenths tenths tenths like
los angeles is filled with tents
like you can't believe it like when i
tell people about it and then they go
there
they're like i thought you were
exaggerating like no i was understating
like los angeles is overwhelmed with
tense it's
[ __ ] crazy like you can't believe
that on la brea
they just allow people to set up tents
everywhere
it's nuts well yeah what are people
going to do that's the question
what are people going to do yeah where
are you going to put them do you have
hospitals available for and a lot of
those the problem is a lot of those
shelters
they won't let them do drugs yeah and a
lot of people like i would rather rather
be in a [ __ ] tent
outside by the beach than be under your
thumb because los angeles doesn't get
cold
you know i mean a cold day is 50
you know it's a big deal right just
sleeping bag you're outside
it's nice yeah it's really emphasized a
lot of these
economic divides you know because
everyone in new york
just orders everything on amazon yeah so
every apartment building in every nice
part of new york
receives a daily shipment of every
tenant's stuff
from amazon and then there's like a
secondary
economy of people just going into all
the buildings and stealing all the
packages
i've seen a lot of that yeah i've seen a
lot of ring videos
the doorbell camera videos of people
stealing [ __ ] oh yeah it's almost
comical i mean i had one where i was
loading my car
with bags at two in the morning on a
tuesday
and in the lobby of my building for
maybe
15 minutes somebody just as soon as i
walk around the corner someone goes and
scoops everything up
yeah it's it's a it's a wild time and
i hope we're coming out of it i mean
right when i came to austin this is the
first time i've
you know been on an airplane since the
beginning of the pandemic you're the
first person i've spoken to without a
mask
no really the first phase did you feel
weird coming in here
but you you knew everyone was tested no
no yeah no i felt
fine i thought i've just been very
careful and
because it's all so cold in new york it
just promotes this
prison cell like lifestyle where i'm
just sitting in my apartment reading and
doing push-ups all day
oh my god yeah yeah the dog [ __ ] thing
is like
so people just don't clean up anymore
they just gave up you know
how it is it's it's there's this kind of
tumbling character where things just
start to accumulate and then no one
shovels the streets and then
it gets easier probably it's harder to
pick it up because there's just like
mounting layers of garbage everywhere
and it just starts to
look increasingly disgusting maybe we'll
we'll just uh get out of this in a
couple weeks and everything will be
oh yeah the problem that i don't think
the people that shut everything down for
a [ __ ] year
ever take into consideration is that
people don't have the resources to
bounce back
things don't bounce back on their own
right peop if you want to start a
business
it takes money like it takes quite a bit
of money to get
a lease to put to stock the shelves
to hire employees and when you've been
out of business for a year you don't
have any money
so you've probably used up all savings
if you had any savings
try getting a loan when you don't have
anything
there's there's really there's no real
logical path forward
for a lot of these businesses in los
angeles 75
of the restaurants are gone oh yeah i'm
so worried about the restaurants in new
york
yeah it's terrible it doesn't seem like
it's even talked about sufficiently
because in new york in the winter time i
mean they're really trying they're doing
things that i would have never like
truly extraordinary things like making
these little
heated space gazebos that are covered in
mylar on the inside and
they're and you know ultimately most
people don't even really want
to do that so then there's this weird
conflict of is it
moral to support these businesses
because you want them to stay
in business or are you feeding into a
system where people are
subjecting themselves to unsafe working
conditions and is it actually
immoral to go to restaurants and of
course people endlessly argue about that
um well personal choices are not immoral
right so if the people decide that
they're willing to work there and
they're masked up and they feel safe
working there isn't that better than not
having a choice to work there
i guess the idea is that it instead of
people going on unemployment they are
feel
pressured to put themselves at risk when
they really should be
at home not potentially spreading
coronavirus
and ideally receiving some sort of
government assistance
well it's all it's also like when does
the government assistance run out
because it has run out for a lot of
people there is no more unemployment for
a lot of folks
and then on top of that the way
everything's been mismanaged is so
terrible in so many ways like why is it
okay to be at target
on top of people why is it okay to be at
walgreens on top of people
but it's not okay to have these mom and
pop stores open or
retail stores oh yeah or you know like i
said i haven't been on an airplane until
i came to see you but of course i see
all these stories in the news that are
like
this guy went on an airplane and he took
off his mask and they had to do an
emergency landing and they kicked him
off the plane and everyone cheered
and if you haven't been on a plane you
just kind of read that and you think oh
yeah
that guy sounds like quite an [ __ ]
good that they kicked him off the plane
but then on the plane i then i hadn't
even considered this like
what what is done with snacks what are
the snack provisions
are there no more peanuts is there no
water and if it is served
then everyone has to take off their
masks so this is all
just sort of like security theater
because they still serve food and
everyone unmasks simultaneously
to eat so there's a period of at least
15 minutes where everyone on the plane
is unmasked by the doing of the actual
airline
yeah it's nonsense it's full nonsense
across the board well i think people
just don't know what to do it's
it's you know they're aware that all
these things are contradictory everyone
is trying to do their best they're
confused they don't understand it even
to this
day um people are trying not to be an
[ __ ]
you know when you wear a mask which
you're basically saying is i'm not an
[ __ ]
you know i'm gonna go around and i want
you to feel like i care
and i want you know i want you to feel
all right
so i'm going to wear a mask but it's not
i mean maybe it's protecting
somewhat it's not certainly not 100 safe
you know like it's protecting you
against droplets
someone sneezes but you're breathing oh
yeah the masking
is definitely good i think that's pretty
well established but
uh i guess what i don't understand is
the hypocrisy like if we have
established that masking is good then we
also have to not
have snacks on the flight or water
or water but yeah yeah so then what do
you do you're on top of each other it's
hitting three people next to each other
i mean it's like
literally the opposite of social
distancing it's incredibly intimate
you don't even know these people you're
touching elbows with them yeah it's
crazy
yeah i mean and this is why when it
started i was one of these people
that you know i was thinking well you
know i work in media
i know the way the media blows
everything out of proportion i remember
swine flu i know that they sell
newspapers by making everyone terrified
this can't possibly be as bad as people
think it is and i
was sort of in covet denial and i was
also in the middle of filming the third
season of my tv show
so i was just sort of seduced by the
momentum of production and didn't want
it to end
and uh and people were saying you know i
don't think we can
film anymore i think we have to stop and
i thought what
is the world going to shut down yeah i
remember that
like this is unprecedented yeah the the
world
isn't going to shut down we're not going
to be
kept in our apartments it's just not
conceivable that such a thing could
happen
cut to one year later
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience